I found out that I'm coming to a place
called Lancaster and the first thing
that comes up when you google Lancaster
Pennsylvania is the Amish folks and the
horses and the buggies so I was like
okay I guess we're going back in time
my name is Mustafa nor a Davi
Jesse Calzado espanha George Tarr Larina
boy I'm at butter sauce born in Iraq dad
in 1998 I was born in I'm raised in
Somalia and I live there up until I was
11 years old I was born at almost the
onset of a civil war in Liberia
I'm originally from Cuba when I was
seven years old I was placed in a raft
that came to America originally I'm from
Nigeria I left my own country because I
am an openly gay man my life was in
danger because of my sexual orientation
and the work I do as an activist and she
doesn't sex our home was attacked
a week later if we move to Syria we went
from Damascus to Budapest Budapest to
New York City and went to Chicago and
then Chicago to Sioux Falls the ole you
act sneaks up on you thought it was
Suk's Falls but to fall as it is
refugees someone who has to leave home
was forced to leave home oftentimes you
know all of a sudden back home there's
something wrong
[Music]
my first day in America was Halloween
day I was just so confused why
everybody's wearing all these costumes
and I just remember thinking I guess we
have to fit in I don't think we brought
the right clothes for this area but I
was confused by the foods like I don't
understand the concept of ranch blue
cheese obviously now I'm obsessively
cheese when I opened the house and I saw
this children and you know they say hey
trick or treat and I assumed that they
like having a welcoming basket for the
new people so I I I took the bag
a lot of people do not know the
difference between economic migrants and
refugees the reason why people flee is
because their lives are in danger the
biggest misconception is that we want to
be refugees well that's just not so
like no one wants to leave home Bena
refugees not a choice is something that
happens to you and you don't have any
control of it the most common
misconception about refugees is that
they are different from you but there
are aspects of the refugee experience
that are relatable to anyone
[Music]
Garfield me is like my boyfriend I'm all
about the Korean barbeque right now I
can eat any type of spicy food would
have strawberries in my country so I
indulged in the strawberries
I absolutely love to shop for my almost
two-year-old I love dressing her up I
love music
mostly British rap I like karaoke my
favorite karaoke song is I did it my way
by Frank Sinatra I loved dancing salsa
dancing booty shaking dancing
a refugee couldn't look like any one
refugee person looks like me this little
cute guy just look at yourselves in the
mirror look at your best friends go
through your Facebook that's exact
there is no image of a refugee that's
not possible think of a neighbor someone
you know your kid goes to school with
the co-worker we're literally people
people just like you when you hear the
word refugee you think about that word
think about what that word represents
think about the distance that is assumed
and work to make that distance less
you
[Music]